[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis à liguori
je suis l'auteur du livre zéro plastique
0 toxiques et je suis consultant en
économie circulaire
je suis ravi d'être ici ce soir
d'autant plus que c'est la deuxième fois
que j'ai l'honneur de donner un taux sur
ce fameux et prestigieux cercle rouge et
ce soir je vais vous parler du place en
plastique
c'est un matériau qui est enfin inscrit
c'est vrai il est bon marché
léger il résistant aux chocs
d'ailleurs on le trouve partout dans
notre maison c'est vrai il constitue
mesure sensible de cuisine nous
emballages même nos moeurs nos vêtements
etc
et d'ailleurs c'est pas combien les
industriels adore le plastique également
pourquoi parce qu'il est bon marché à
produire et en plus on peut lui faire
adopter toutes les formes et les
couleurs qu'on veut c'est d'ailleurs de
là qui tire son nom puisqu'il est alors
aujourd'hui on trouve le plastique un
peu partout qu'est ce que c'est tactique
le plastique c'est ce qu'on appelle un
polymère c'est à dire que c'est un amas
de molécules identiques qui pour la
quasi totalité des fois elles
proviennent du pétrole et sésame à ces
molécules on va les faire s'accrocher
par an processus convaincre et la peau
libération ça c'est la base du plastique
c'est un peu comme quand vous faites un
gâteau vous à les mélanger de la farine
et de l'eau ça va être la plage de votre
gâteau mais encore faut-il ajouter des
ingrédients pour lui donner du goût de
la couleur la texture et c'est bien pour
les fasti c'est pareil on va rajouter
des additifs que ce soit la cie fiant
colorants des assouplissant etc alors ça
peut être des fallas qui vont venir
assouplir donner la flexibilité haut
placé ça peut être des vies ses notes
pour la propriété un petit matériel ou
encore du dioxyde de titane pour
blanchir un petit en fait c'est comme un
gâteau selon les ingrédients selon les
additifs que vous allez choisir
vous pouvez obtenir une multitude de
plastique différents rien à voir des
souple des durs des tirs avec cetera
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il est
allemand ne devrait pas parler du
plastique mais p&c plastique
on les voit partout dans notre quotidien
à tel point que dans le monde
c'est aujourd'hui la troisième le
troisième matériau le plus fabriqué au
monde après la cl sinon c'est
aujourd'hui dans le monde 10 tonnes de
plastique qui sont produites chaque
seconde
maintenant si je vous dis mais plastique
n'est pas vraiment le meilleur ami de
l'environnent probablement pas vous
étonne
vous allez peut-être avoir dans l'esprit
ces images de torture de donc faire un
avec une paille dans le nez ou coincé
dans un sac plastique
même si les pollutions marines par le
plastique sont malheureusement réelles
elles ne représentent en réalité une
petite partie des impacts
environnementaux des plastiques pourquoi
parce que quand vous jetez vos déchets
dans votre quotidien
ils ne finissent généralement pas dans
l'océan mais en centre de traitement des
déchets ça peut être soit un
incinérateur
soyez des chiens dans le premier cas
dans le cas de l'incinérateur nos
déchets vont être bruit vont ainsi formé
des fumée très toxique
heureusement elles vont être filtrées
avant d'être rejetées dans l'air mais
qui filtre qui les filtrations 10
filtres qu'est-ce qu'on en fait de ces
filtres une fois qu'ils sont chargés de
substances toxiques
eh bien ils vont représenter des déchets
très dangereux à prêter c'est également
le cas de ce qu'on appelle le mâchefer
ce sont ces résidus de déchets qui n'ont
pas réussi à être brûlé dans le deuxième
cas le cadet des charges pendant leur
fermentation leur décomposition
les déchets sont plastique ou non vont
former des jus très toxique qu'on
appelle des leaks bien en il arrive bien
souvent que la bâche de protection des
déchets au fur et à mesure des années
sabine et il peut arriver qu'on seront
dans ces cas là il va y avoir des hauts
risques de pollution des sols et les
nappes phréatiques par ses jupes indique
si ça ce sont les impacts
environnementaux dvd plastique en tant
que déchet mais c'est donc sans parler
les autres impacts environnementaux des
déchets des plastiques
par exemple pendant la fabrication du
plastique
quand on va extraire du pétrole il va y
avoir deux au risque de pollution des
sols
quand on va le transformer en plastique
on va utiliser et donc rejeter des
substances très toxiques
vous voyez le constat n'est pas vraiment
glorieux
ok mais que faire certains d'entre vous
vont peut-être me dire c'est la
responsabilité des dirigeants politiques
c'est à eux de faire des lois pour
interdire ce genre de substance et de
pratiquer d'autres qu'on peut être me
dire c'est aux fabricants d'arrêter de
polluer et d'utiliser ce type de
substance
d'autres encore ont peut-être me dire
c'est un bouc consommateurs de changer
nos habitudes de consommation et ainsi
de plus nécessiter la fabrication de ces
documents est bien aucun de ces trois
arguments matin effectivement
l'engagement de chacun de ces trois
types d'acteurs c'est à dire la sphère
politique
les fabricants et les consommateurs est
nécessaire mais à lucelle insuffisant
c'est donc bien l'engagement simultanée
de ces trois types d'acteurs qui peuvent
réellement déclencher une vraie
transition
c'est le constat que j'ai fait il ya
cinq ans il ya cinq ans j'ai lu un
article sur les impacts environnementaux
des déchets particulièrement des
plastiques ya cinq ans j'ai ainsi
réalisé les impacts environnementaux que
je gêne irait directement par mes choix
quotidien j'ai ainsi réalisé les actions
environnementales qui était dans mes
cordes de consommateurs ne seraient
jamais pas simplement a signé quelques
pétitions et faire un don pour une
association
je pouvais pas en réalité bien plus que
cela je pouvais réduire les impacts
environnementaux que moi je générer
directement par les gestes du quotidien
et je pouvais en plus de ça encourager
ou non certaines pratiques les
fabricants ou la fabriquons la
fabrication de certains volumes c'est
donc décidé de se jeter à l'eau j'ai
commencé à changer ce que je consommais
et où je consommais mais j'avais
toujours un maître de la simplicité
j'avais décidé de choisir uniquement des
recettes des actions des astuces très
simple facile et rapide
pourquoi parce que je voulais que sa
démarche environnementale ne me prennent
ni du temps ni plus d'argent et ne soit
pas une source ni de frustration
oui de sa pub vi j'ai donc commencé à
réduire les emballages alimentaires que
j'ai acheté pour ça j'ai commencé à
acheter en vrac au marché chez les
petits commerces
j'ai commencé à utiliser moins de
produits à usage unique comme les cotons
démaquillants les rasoirs les emballages
les essuie-tout et caetera et je les ai
remplacé par des alternatives
réutilisables c'est à dire la vague
j'ai aussi remplacer mes cosmétiques
parle des ingrédients plus écologique et
très simples comme du beurre de karité
des huiles végétales et même les
ingrédients de mon frigo j'ai remplacé
mes produits ménagers par du vinaigre
blanc ou encore j'ai arrêté d'acheter
des ustensiles de cuisine en plastique
et j'ai préféré les mains conviant plus
simple et plus écologiques comme le vert
le père ton minox ou le bois
ainsi avec ses astuces très simple et en
une année j'ai réduit mes déchets
plastiques et non pas steve de 80% alors
j'ai été moi-même tout aussi surprise
que bout je ne m'attendais pas avec des
astuces aussi simple à pouvoir revient
au temps de mes enfants environnementaux
mais j'ai été surprise par une deuxième
chose moi qui pensais qu'un quotidien
écologie coûter plus cher était réservée
qu'à certains budgets
c'est par exemple le cas des voitures et
écrits sont très chères à l'achat gars
j'ai réalisé que ce n'était absolument
pas le cas de la réduction de la
consommation de plastique
bien au contraire je faisais des
économies pourquoi parce que j'achetais
des objets d'occasion pour ne pas
nécessiter la refabrication neuf et
ainsi j'avais des prix deux à trois fois
moins élevés qu'en magasin
parce que j'avais remplacé mes produits
ménagers et mes cosmétiques par des
ingrédients à la fois écologique sain et
bon marché ou encore parce que j'avais
investi dans des objets réutilisables
et non pas jetable j'ai ainsi régulier
avec ses petites astuces mais dépenses
du quotidien c'est-à-dire l'alimentation
les vêtements et cosmétiques les
produits ménagers de 30%
j'ai enfin été surprise par une
troisième chose vous vous souvenez de
ces additifs dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure mais il fallait les bisphénols
et bien en réalité ces additifs du
plastique peuvent migrer vers notre
poids alors comment c'est possible
par exemple ils peuvent migrer dans
notre alimentation
quand un plastique est en contact
prolongé avec un aliment surtout si cet
aliment est soit gras sur la sim soit
chaud dans ces substances sont dans nos
produits ménagers on va les inhaler
parties sont dans nos cosmétiques
ils vont pénétrer notre peau or une fois
dans notre corps et plus précisément
dans notre sens ces substances sont ce
qu'on appelle les perturbateurs
endocriniens à dire qu'elles vont
potentiellement venir perturber le
fonctionnement normal de nos hormones et
donc de nos organes la théorie de le
colon etc
plus concrètement les conséquences
peuvent être par exemple une
augmentation des risques de cancer mais
aussi une diminution de la qualité et la
quantité des sternes que vous produisez
messieurs chez les femmes il peut y
avoir une risques de puberté précoce de
tumeurs ovariennes etc
moi non plus
le constat n'est pas vraiment glorieux
d'accord mais que faire eh bien ces
astuces très simple qui est me
permettait de réduire les impacts
environnementaux me permettait en
réalité également de réduire des
explosifs
à ces additifs du plastique et donc
alors risque pourquoi parce que
j'utilisais des produits ménagers et des
cosmétiques +1 et parce que je m'étais
moins un contact mon alimentation avec
des plastiques
cette démarche qui paie donc
initialement environnement servir est
également facile économique est très
avantageuse pour ma propre santé et vous
choisissiez de trois quatre cinq petites
astuces simples et économiques pour leur
petit à petit votre consommation de
plastique au quotidien et si vous
choisissez des astuces qui vous font
envie typique votre curiosité vous
pouvez par exemple décidé d'acheter plus
d'objets d'occasion pour ne pas
nécessiter la fabrication de nouveaux
objets neufs
vous pouvez décider d'acheter de plus en
plus vous aliments secs en vrac
vous pouvez remplacer aux produits
ménagers par du vinaigre blanc ou vos
cosmétiques par des ingrédients simples
par exemple remplacer votre stick à
lèvres par du beurre de karité
vous pouvez encore réduire votre
utilisation d'objets à usage unique et
préférer leur alternative relizane bref
prenez des astuces qui vous plaisent des
astuces vous correspondre et
correspondre à votre objet à votre
quotidien et à vos habitudes
mais surtout n'oubliez pas une chose
l'objectif n'est pas nécessairement de
tout faire mais de faire votre part à
votre rythme cria votre men
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]